rui pour vol c'est au tour des ados de
passer en coulisses les désinvolte le
cru 2 saint-pryvé-saint-mesmin monte sur
scène c'est le moment de tout donner
[Musique]
dans la salle de répétition
concentration extrême pour l'autre
groupe orléanais hop écroué
ils passent en dernier dans la catégorie
méga kron op cruz n'en est pas à sa
première participation mais il a la
pression devant son public
il faut se qualifier pour la finale
c'est la première fois d'ailleurs
qu'elle est organisée à orléans un
événement porté par l'adjoint aux sports
et à la jeunesse
on se veut une ville qui participe au
rayonnement d'événement majeur sur notre
territoire donc celui ci en fait partie
dans un secteur qui qui peut sembler un
peu confidentiel mais qui touche
énormément de public faut pas oublier
que le hip hop c'est une culture qui a
capté d'une quarantaine d'années
aujourd'hui dont se saisissent beaucoup
beaucoup de français beaucoup dans les
années puisqu'il danse le hip hop est
une culture urbaine forte
devenu incontournable ça dépasse les
préjugés les quartiers tout ce que l'on
peut penser du hip hop c'est un moyen de
les commentaires communier les gens un
moyen intergénérationnel de réunir les
gens des passionnés autour des bonnes
valeurs sportives artistiques comme on
aime tous les groupes sont passés les
désinvolte attendent les résultats mais
ça ne passera pas pour eux pas assez
préparés pour agrafer enfance et paca
[Musique]
dans la catégorie méga cros en revanche
hop écroué qualifier pour la finale
mais la partie n'est pas terminée demain
c'est le billet pour les championnats du
monde aux états unis qui se joue
[Applaudissements]